i'm not sure because you kind of you say
a lot of things that are are very much
like feminists like feminists say them
but at the same time you're not sure if
you're you identify as a focus right
yeah the reason why i have difficulty
pegging myself as a feminist is
i feel like it
i think society's viewpoint of feminism
is extreme okay you know because
oftentimes when we see feminists it's
the more extreme side of it right like
we could say the same thing for certain
religions races whatever it may be so in
this case like the social construct of
feminism and equality or equity
like people tend to look at it in a
negative way and i'm very much an equal
rights equal less person you know like
if i see a woman is [ __ ] up i will
call it out like it is
like i i fully believe in that because i
feel like a lot of people do let women
get away with bs that doesn't need to be
happening okay so i think that's the
reason why i don't really come off as a
feminist per se i think i just really
believe in
what kind of bs do you think that women
get away with
sometimes abusing men i feel like that's
like the most basic thing that i could
come up with now
um
because like i said briefly in the last
uh time that i was here like my mom was
abusing my dad straight up but my dad
couldn't really do much about it you
know because like
everyone's thinking like oh this poor
woman
she must be getting abused by her man so
she has to fight back or something like
nah it's not it's really not like that
it's really my mom being abusive and
people would be very quick to take a
woman's side in a case where she very
well might be wrong like the johnny depp
case right now yeah that is a freaking
mess like we need to hold this woman
accountable she is a menace to society
so what like what points do you agree
with feminism on
what where do you think um like what
what are we missing in 2020 don't you
think that because feminism like came in
waves didn't it she had first wave
second wave third wave feminism so
i think it's kind of difficult to answer
that because i need like a an example
right so that i can say like yeah i
agree or no i don't and this is why
because like first wave feminism i agree
with okay personally
women want equality you want equal pay
you know you want to be treated just as
a man's treated i'm down with that i
think the the waves after that it got
progressively and progressively worse in
my personal point of view like it for me
feminism became
not so much equality but now about
revenge
and
i said on my show the other day right
that
feminism this newer form of feminism has
given women the power
to be
just like the most heinous man or the
most heinous men in history
right you know the abusers the sexual
abusers the people that used to talk to
people derogatory but giving them the
the get out of not having accountability
for doing it
that's what i believe feminism today has
done i believe it's you can say you know
what [ __ ] men they're this they're trash
and there's no accountability on your
side but see i feel like that's not true
feminism then i think that's just being
a misandrist at the end of the day like
that's something that's not spoken about
enough though miss andrew he's not
spoken about enough oh i agree i think
that's like 90 percent of feminists
today if i'm being honest like
when when i talk to most feminists they
have a slight disdain for men
like even if i say oh we need men in
society like we argue
well i believe in that because we need a
balance at the end of the day we we're
gonna need both men and women at the end
of the day if we're going to
function properly because there's some
things that men can do and some things
that women can do that the other
gender sex cannot provide you need men
to build stuff
if you're honest yeah no i mean they
didn't mean like a shelf
no like the man
like are we talking about like building
the shelf from ikea like no like that
the mic that you're using right now
this stuff yeah like they run the
infrastructure of society like most if
men disappeared today society would
collapse if women disappeared it
wouldn't
outside of reproductive reasons yeah i
can agree with that
but i always bring it back to the
foundation of what like these countries
and infrastructure has been built on
right so like which is when we look at
like stem majors for example a lot of
engineering all that kind of stuff uh
it's not woman dominated whatsoever you
know like
i don't know what the statistics are
exactly but i i can guarantee you it's
it's definitely going to be less than 30
of women in stem or something it's
changed a lot throughout the last like
10 to 15 years that's a guarantee but
before then it was mostly men in these
types of positions and majors and all
that because
women weren't really given an interest
into it they weren't really given a
like a pathway but now that they are
it's enjoyable yeah and it's great that
we're in it now but not everybody is no
but now they are they're not choosing
them
they're not choosing that women
generally aren't choosing the stem
fields
i feel like i know a lot of women in
stem but i can only speak from
statistically they're not choosing it
yeah it's just like the numbers don't
back that up so because if you if they
um they did a study where they took the
countries that have the most choice when
it comes to like jobs you know i'm
saying like so you take like
more you know like middle eastern
countries where women have less choice
and you take more egalitarian countries
where women have more choice and the
more choice that women have like the the
more they choose jobs that have to do
with people and not things
because women like we value
relationships yeah so you'll see more
women going into like medicine yeah like
midwifery and that's what like this
would be a midwife so yeah social care
and and realistically though that's
because that's our strength you know we
have a nurturing kind of nature to us
that men often times cannot provide at
the end of the day yeah so like i see
nothing wrong with women not stepping
into stem more than before
like it's okay
i i do agree with you in that sense that
like hey man so then if if you believe
in like equal
or if feminists believe in like equal
um
opportunities right
you don't even equal opportunity doesn't
um equal equal outcome
we talked about this briefly
i agreed
i agreed with that fully i'm the type of
person where it's like if you can't step
up to the plate and deliver
it's not for you point blank period like
and if you really want to continue
whatever field you're going into by all
means do so but you're gonna have to
work twice as hard you know and
especially if you're a woman you know
and in a male dominated situation you
might be looked at a little bit more
crazy so
so what do you think like feminists are
really fighting for in 2022 because i
just like genuinely bottom of my heart i
feel like as a woman i'm not oppressed
at all i don't think there's anything
stopping i'm in a very male-dominated
sector of youtube and i think being a
woman's an advantage not a disadvantage
your subscribership keeps going up and
up and up yeah like i i honestly i've
always been in like male dominated
fields fields i worked in sales and i my
mom was also in a male dominated field
and we've always said no it's an
advantage
um because you stand out more okay um so
i just
i can't think of anything like any
rights that i don't have in 2022. well
if we look at what's going on now
especially in like a couple of states
like
south and west word at least in the us
there's a lot of
bodily autonomy issues that i think like
that so abortion yeah things like that
exactly but then there's also like cases
where gynecologists male gynecologists
specifically will impregnate women with
their own sperm like crazy things like
that like i think how often does that
happen though it doesn't matter how
often it happens the problem is that it
happens at all
and it happens enough for us to talk
about it and we know about it
i don't know what i'm saying no but i
don't i don't advocate for it i don't
advocate for it
okay
okay finish your sentence yeah go around
[ __ ]
finish your so so in general i think the
fight for feminism now
mostly revolves around sexual assault
um or any type of domestic violence and
bodily autonomy i think that's what
we're
mainly pushing for at least okay and
what were you gonna say sorry yeah
because like i i obviously i don't
advocate for you know gynecologists and
pregnant impregnating their patients
yeah but um
listen anomalies happen
that's an uh i would guess that's an
anomaly um when it comes to uh
bodily autonomy or abortion i personally
have very strong views on abortion i
don't believe in abortion i don't
believe women should be able to kill um
children in their womb just because they
made a mistake sexually i don't like um
i feel like if you make that mistake
that's your mistake that's your burden
to handle you know i don't believe that
you should be using
abortion as contraception because prior
to getting pregnant you have
multiple ways as to not get pregnant you
know there's multiple ways not to get
pregnant and if you and if you have
chosen by for whatever reason not to do
that then that baby's yours and not only
yours it's also the guy that you were
having sex with
i fully understand and i agree with you
to a certain extent the issue here is
that
i think a majority of the time that
abortion does happen it's not just
because somebody was
willy-nilly just being sexually active
and did a whoopsie daisy
yes like it actually is i think it is it
actually is
only only uh okay so i'll give
statistics so about which country are we
talking about um the uk the us and the
uk one percent about one to two percent
of abortions are because someone was
either graped or molested right the
other
um there's a i think maybe
five percent because the contraception
didn't work okay the rest of them is
because people wanted to have sex and
and they made them know where you got
these statistics from i'll get them for
you because i did that on my show okay
don't pull out your phone
yeah
whatever
no i i think it'd be like we're this is
uh like we can do it because no because
jessica like honestly every girl i know
that's had an abortion they were
irresponsible like they weren't even on
birth control or pulling yeah so like in
case i understand no in that case i
fully understand because like my dad
raised me to believe the same thing like
he was like listen at the end of the day
if you feel like you're grown enough to
get sexually active you better put on
your big girl panties and know what
might come out of it right so i fully
agree with that but in a case where
somebody is assaulted or incest or
anything like
that so so would you if there was a law
that said it was only in the case of
assault or great that abortion is
allowed would you agree with that then
like because i think it's hard it's hard
to
like say whether or not i would agree
with it
i feel like to a certain extent i would
but then it's still
controlling women's bodies and what
choices they get to make that's the
other problem that i'm struggling with
it's like this is where i struggle with
figuring out whether i'm a feminist or
not yeah because it's like yes i fully
believe in bodily autonomy i believe
that we should be able to make the
decisions that we want to with our
bodies
however
there that a line can be drawn you know
especially when it comes to abortion
like so from the sorry to cut you from
the good marker institute it says 13
they do like white papers all the time
can you pronounce it this is a german
organization
it says that german organization well
german
it says 13 so it's 13 was because of the
pill okay so 13 of abortions they said
the women were saying i was on the pill
i didn't work
so 13 so if we got 13 because of pill
and then we've got
one percent because of grape
that that's only what let's say 15 yeah
so let's say the majority 85 of
abortions are because of bad sexual
practice
yeah but then that then we'd have to
bring it back another step we'd have to
think about the sexual education
uh system then because it's like why are
people having children so willy-nilly
then right why are they so comfortable
with
did you know what's interesting we have
more access to contraception
and more access to sexual education
and
more out of wedlock pregnancies
so what does that say about a society so
so then
where is the evidence that sex ed
and contraception has been helpful
like it seems like if anything it's had
the opposite effect here's the thing
just because we have more access to it
doesn't mean that it is successful right
right so a lot of like we have to think
about like again i can only speak on the
us terms because i don't i don't know
like the school system anywhere else but
when you look at
the school curriculum state by state
they're all wildly different like if you
look at texas versus new jersey
we're learning two completely different
things prioritizing different things at
least there are a lot of schools out
there that bark at students to practice
abstinence rather than safe sex right
and we already know how young teens
minds go they're going to be like oh but
i really want to do it yeah why can't i
do it i went to one of those schools
yeah but to be honest there were no
pregnancies in my school yeah i mean and
so like i i just that's why i don't
really buy into like the sex ed thing
because if that was true like we would
be running crazy with with pregnant kids
because all we had every year was an
abstinent speaker and honestly like
like it helped like i was a virgin's
time like 1920 and that was that was
later than most like you know what i
mean but like i think that really also
depends on the culture of like where
you're from right like if you're from a
more conservative area i think naturally
it might be more like that but i'm from
a more liberal area
so
my school personally didn't have like
teen pregnancies like at all
but i know a couple of neighboring
schools that did have issues with that
and it's like
their sex ed
you know classes weren't necessarily the
best on top of the fact that most of
them were from lower income uh areas so
i'm just curious like what would good
sex ad look like to you so like what
would if you're in a perfect like chess
gets to make the laws
like what what really putting me on the
spot today
i'm just curious like what would that
look like for you um i would want um
students to know
every single available option that they
have because i don't think people
realize how many options they have for
contraception okay right what age would
you teach it
well i started learning sex ed in fifth
grade i think that's i don't know what
it is what age is that oh god that's
about
10 or 11 years old that's a little young
for i mean you say that now but
you could get your period as young as
nine years old so you kind of have to do
they're giving talks in schools schools
now about transgenderism at like eight
so
i don't know
um okay so you would put so in 10 11
that's yeah i'd probably go for about
that age range because that is exactly
when our bodies start changing rapidly
so and you would tell them like okay if
you had like this is what sex is from
the school yeah and you would from the
school say
these contraceptions this is what you
can use yeah like this is what happens
out of sex i think the the problem
is that oftentimes school really just
like looks at sex from a very scientific
perspective and they expect the students
to learn
the more emotional aspect from their
parents but we can't really trust
so i'm just curious like so you bring in
10 11 year olds and you would say this
is how to have like this is not how to
this is what sex is but in other words
like later on kind of yeah but like how
to have sex
in a way
i mean yeah but like the thing is i have
that conversation with my son the other
day
and he's nine okay i never told i just
asked him as a matter of fact has he
heard of what sex is
and he's like yeah it's when people kiss
and i was like okay
yeah do you know what i'm saying so the
thing is that at this age
children unfortunately are being exposed
yeah more so to what sex is or sexual
type even sexual type language
is being used within schools nowadays
you know i mean i don't think it's just
nowadays i think it's even from when we
were young and even some of our parents
generation you look at cartoons and tv
shows and all that always see these like
subliminal messages like oh my god all
the time like they were always dirty
powerpuff girls can we talk about the
mayor can we talk about the mayor
have you not seen that there's a there's
a youtube clip about um the cartoons
yeah they made a cartoon clip of all the
cartoons when you were young that had
sexual innuendo and they put them all
together and watching it you're like
this is what i was watching this is some
crazy like i will never forget spongebob
pulling out some soap and telling gary
like don't drop them cause like they
were acting like pirates and he's like
look doubloons and yeah and it's like
not only are we bringing in a
sexual assault joke but also
jail what's this but what's disney doing
now with the cartoons right there's a
whole thing about disney bringing in the
whole translating with the cartoons and
that whole thing so yeah i just think i
don't know i think children are being
exposed to um but i mean what's going on
what's wrong with that though i'm trying
to understand i think you should protect
kid's innocence honestly like because
once what's not innocent about about
being transgender
no i'm i'm looking at you
because because transgenderism is like
it's an anomaly
right and it's like children that much
of an anomaly if we have to talk about
it is my point though yeah but children
all right so
but children shouldn't be taught about
in my personal point of view shouldn't
we talk about shouldn't be taught about
sex at a young age anyway especially not
a sexual orientation that in my personal
point of view is about um
confusion
more so than sexual orientation so it's
like are you trying to show children
that
this sexual orientation is quote unquote
normal
where if we look at it it isn't it's a
it's first of all it's an anomaly second
of all they talk about it's it can be a
while
it can be it hang on
psychological or physiological because
they say gender dysphoria
gen
explaining to a nine-year-old child what
gender dysphoria is they don't know what
gender is for you so it you could keep
it simplistic is my point you have to
keep it kid-friendly but the thing is
transgenderism isn't simplistic
you're making it seem like it's far more
complicated than it is you can just say
here is someone who was born a boy they
don't feel comfortable being a boy they
don't feel like they're right in their
body and in their mind they feel more
comfortable with playing with the girls
yeah they he they like playing with the
dolls and the makeup and whatever it may
be that
well i know
that's
that's exposing them to like mental
issues at such a young age yeah so you
think being trans is a mental issue
of course it is it's not a phys it's not
a biological uh you don't have to say of
course yeah take it down a notch no but
it's no but it's true it's not it's not
a biological one
it's a mental one right if you think
you're something that you're actually
not that's in your head
just like you think you're a ten out of
ten what
how adam said i never said that you
think you're 11 out of 10 which is in
your head so what i'm trying to say is
if you're if you're talking about
something that isn't if we can look in
your body and we can see you have two
testicles on the penis
we know what you are right if you think
you are other than what you actually are
that's something going on in your head
right because couldn't i identify as a
teenager
if i wanted to trans age they call it
no i'm serious no i've gone into this
what if i said i feel i feel 17. yeah i
am 17. well that would genuinely be
something that you would have to work
with and being someone who studies psych
yeah that would more than likely be a
trauma response
because so he's transgender
i was not done speaking
people who struggle
with their age at least right
um who still feel like they're stuck in
their teen years or even childhood years
usually experience some sort of terrible
trauma at that age in their life and
that's where they feel emotionally and
physically stunted yeah so that's why
like maybe later on they still act a
certain way for years but it's
interesting because you're kind of
saying like that's a that's like a
mental disorder yeah no i can't i can
say that with peace yeah
but but trans wouldn't be so trans women
i can't see it that way because i'm
someone who's part of the lgbt community
yeah and i see how these people struggle
and
like you know like people tend to make
the argument that it's an emotional
response it's not a logical one
do you want an answer or not yeah but
it's not
an emotional response yes it's a yes or
no question
it's a yes or no question a logical one
it's a yes or no question
let's talk about the facts not the
feelings please
guys get along
let's talk about the facts of the
feelings it's like
regardless these things were removed
from the dsm-5 yeah uh being transgender
gender dysphoria is still in there i
believe and they're working on the dsm-6
i believe if not it's already out but um
it's difficult to pinpoint that as a
mental illness
only because this is a whole
this is something that someone's willing
to change their entire life for i
changed my entire life to be seventeen
i mean [ __ ] you could try you could try
hang on rachel dolezal changed her
entire life to be black oh my gosh do
you know who that is yeah right she was
head of the naacp
and she was a white woman yeah so just
because she identifies or thought of
herself as black doesn't mean that she
is but that doesn't make these people
any less human i think that's what i'm
trying to do we're not no but we're not
talking as i'm saying you're talking
from an emotional standpoint i never
said trans people or whoever you are are
less human they are human beings they
deserve their rights as a human human
being
but it doesn't mean that what they're
saying respect their identity is the
issue
so if a trans person would mean respect
their identity if somebody were to come
to you right now they were trans they
once were she
and became he
and you knew this
would you refer to them as
what they are comfortable with or what
they were originally born as i would
refer to them as who they are which is a
man or a woman biologically because what
you're asking me to do essentially so
then that's just disrespectful no it's
not just
disregard no i tell you i'll tell you
what's disrespectful what's
disrespectful for me is to ask me to buy
into your delusion
that's what i think is disrespectful if
i come up to you and say listen i know
i'm a black man but please call me uh
mei ling because i'm now a chinese woman
you're going to be like
all right you're a chinese i'm a chinese
woman really and you've met me and you
know me prior to me identifying as a
chinese woman you're now going to call
me meiling i'm now asking you
to id to buy into my delusion if i feel
like this that's
100 cool but i shouldn't ask you
to buy into what i think of myself
because like i said you think of
yourself as a
11 out of 10
right if you went around asking people
to call you an 11 out of ten and that's
just plain arrogant and egotistical
because you're awesome i wouldn't do
that though right but
yeah but trans people do all i ask is
basic respect
people do they ask people to call them
the thing that they know that they
actually aren't
or the way they see themselves genuinely
not that hard to just refer to them as
she her or he him as they ask and by the
name that they choose to go by it's
genuinely not that hard my name is
francesco right but i go by chesca that
is my preferred name all i have to do is
tell you hey this is what i prefer to be
called feel free to call me this right
and it would be up to you to call me
chesca i would like i said i would
prefer it if you call me francesca i'm
not going to respond because
realistically i i don't like that name
as much as jessica it's that song in
your name it's a it's a respect thing
it's no it's not shooting in your name
yeah is not the same as asking me to
call you by a totally different gender
okay so there's no part of you that is
that gender if they preferred a
different name even you wouldn't go with
that
if they preferred it like i said you're
asked i'm not about they went with a
different name i am not buying it into
someone's dilution yes or no say again
it's really not that hard of a question
afterwards
if they asked me to call them a name if
i came to you and i said i prefer the
name richard even though i clearly am
not biologically male i'll be like what
should what are your parents okay what
are your parents you're not my parents
so you wouldn't have a right to call me
whatever you wouldn't have the right ask
me to call you right you wouldn't have
the right to call me by whatever my
parents call me because my parents are
different from you you're just a 40 year
old man okay you're just a stranger that
i see on the planet do not touch me now
you're just a stranger that i see on a
podcast so jessica like okay
so i i honestly if i if i knew something
no we call that we call that sign
language over here
if i knew someone that was trans i would
probably like i probably would call them
by their name like just because they
asked me to but but the issue i get is
when we start letting people live in
delusion there's consequences and i
really do on some level think that it's
delusional because you're saying you're
something you're not
and and the problem is now we have leah
thomas coming in who's that leah thomas
the swimmer the swimmer okay and
swimming in the women's division
and taking away opportunities from women
like real biological women because in my
opinion
we we started by letting them live in
delusion
okay and it slowly got to the point that
now actual real women are losing
opportunities in athletics right okay
right that's what happens when you live
that's that's what happens when you say
oh but they feel a certain way so we
have to respect it
genuinely it has real world as much as i
would love to um
you know give a viewpoint on that i
can't
because
one i'm not trans i feel like i can't
speak on it until i speak to other trans
people who are athletes as well as
cisgender people who are athletes and
see how they feel about it and two i'm
still
curating my research on that because
i'll be honest
throughout high school i felt that way
yeah i was like why the hell are trans
people ending up in
divisions that i feel like they're not
supposed to be i realized that so that
happened at your school
no
i realized that um
it was me
denying their identity in a sense right
um i know that realistically no matter
what this person was born opposite of
what they are but i do not want to i uh
deny how they feel
and what they've experienced since more
than likely such a young age about what
they identify as
but at the same time like i have to look
at the science behind this right like
because i've seen a lot of trans people
come out and say like listen my my body
has changed completely specifically with
women at least trans women
um they're like
i don't understand why people get so
upset about trans women entering women's
divisions because estrogen really does
break down our like muscle mass and like
our strength that we had as men
previously yeah bone density though
no i'm just i'm sure but that's what i'm
saying that's why i'm saying like i have
to do more research on it first before i
can really curate an idea on it um but
i'm kind of like tutoring with it
because i could understand like i used
to feel that way genuinely like i was
like yo i'm a girl and i i feel like i'm
fighting for my [ __ ] life and it's
already hard enough as a black girl at
that right like
we we have to deal with [ __ ] from
both racism and sexism yeah well i just
think it's like disrespectful to like to
honestly to when real women like women
that were born that way because we go
through [ __ ] they'll never go through
they will never go for a smear test yeah
but here there's nothing to understand
like like what do we deem a real woman
though like i'm just curious what's a
real woman a woman that was born
biologically
with a what is it
the few girls that have fertility issues
but that's very different than
surgically changing a dick into a vagina
okay no i i hear you i hear you
um
i think again like because i'm part of
the community yeah i have more insight
on how they feel about it yeah and i can
go off of that better as opposed to the
like i said this isn't how you feel not
done talking i know you know but i'm
just letting you know this
about how you feel when i'm
when i'm done speaking when i'm done
speaking listen why are you talking
about feelings we're talking about facts
you're gonna have to stop him before i
do
what are you gonna do
there's no listen
what are you what are you trying to do
nothing i'm just asking the question so
like so like it's a it's a we're all
talking right yeah but that's what i'm
saying we've been able to interact fine
yeah and you know if we cut each other
off we're like all right like gucci like
oh wait my bad like whatever i just
don't know right here just keep popping
like i just don't like anything
like you just don't like being cut off
by a man that's what it is like it is so
irritating you don't like being cut off
by a man no because you keep on saying
like oh facts over feelings facts over
feelings like no like at least when
pearl is interrupting me she's saying
like oh wait but
like this is this is what i see this is
what i know you're just saying no facts
over feelings
what if he puts butt facts over
he could get [ __ ] slapped i just like
like do you know what i'm saying like
really like and i think what he's trying
to say is like their feelings about it
don't really matter
it's all about like but if we function
if we functioned off of only logic and
reality we would be a heartless society
genuinely i believe that
i don't know i think i think
carlos in second place
the girl that got second to leah thomas
would be cool right now okay so okay
balance is needed okay times have we
looked at like politicians for example
just going based off of their emotions
sheer emotions yeah like
and not even in a not even close to
logical sense you can find a balance
between emotion and logic yeah you can
find a common ground i fully understand
anyway
we can find a balance between emotion
and logic i do believe that there are
times where we have too much logic and
too much emotion right
ah what do you think that was too much
emotion or too much logic i think it was
me telling you to shut the [ __ ] up
because you don't know how to sometimes
but anyway
i said what i said all right no i hate
you i had you i had you to go hand in
hand in times like this when there's too
much emotion involved people can
genuinely get hurt
and when it comes to logic i feel like
logic most of the time you can't go
wrong but sometimes when we're too
logical it can really disregard a group
of people or whatever it may be you know
yeah but that's that but that's one of
the problems i'm talking about we're not
talking about disregarding people
but that's not one
but
the fact that people um
actually think that speaking things that
make sense is disregarding people is
where we have a problem in the society
because if somebody is speaking to make
sense and you take it as oh you're
disregarding me no like i said i think
these people trans people deserve their
human rights i don't think of them as
less as a human being i'm saying when it
comes to things like you coming into ah
and when it comes don't speak when it
comes to you um going into a sports
arena that is not actually meant for you
and it's meant for biological women then
we see real world consequences to um
your feelings and people catering to
people's feelings that's what i'm saying
but
again i said that i cannot curate an
opinion on that until i do more research
i will not open my mouth on something
that i don't know
[ __ ] about
at the end of the day you know like that
that would just be dumb so but okay so
for you the main thing that you agree
with feminism on like the main rights
that women need to see today is abortion
bodily autonomy
because it's not always just you know
it's not it's not just abortion like in
some states or at least some counties
it's legal for
a police officer to assault an inmate
that's
while they're in custody right like so
let's say i were to be um arrested
and a cop could take me to whatever
little jail cell at whatever little
uh you know place for custody
he could sexually assault me legally
are you sure yes
okay i promise you can do some research
on it i have seen
hang on you can legally sexually assault
somebody yes
a cop specifically like what are you
talk what are we classing a sexual
assault now that's what i'm trying to
understand so what what is this sexual
assault that this man can do legally
what is it that he can do grape
legally yes technically he can yeah in
some states it's like an outdated law
but it's still in place and it does
happen to people
i mean i'd love to see the research on
that i'm not going to i'd love to see
the research on that do you have it i'm
just curious
i'll see if i can find it because i i've
just never that sounds like kind of
wild to me can i can i before we get
before we continue here
just point out um cheska's female
privilege i said when she threatened to
slap me did you think that do you think
that it would have been received well if
i threatened to slap her
if it would have been received the same
way i'm just asking that's it
right okay
just glad we're just just establishing
that
um
okay you don't believe in abortion sarah
no i i i think abortions are quote
unquote okay in
in in instances of grape and molestation
because if sex is non-consensual sorry
if sex is con is consensual
and you had non-consensual sex and a
baby is a result of that
that actual act was non-consensual so i
get i understand why you'd want to get
rid of the child because the sex was
non-consensual so the child would be
non-consensual
if you have consensual sex
and the child is a result then you've
consented to having a child i'm just big
into like taking ownership like i just
feel like deal with the consequences
that you chose right like like you you
picked it and i said i i'm pearl i made
a um i done a live on abortion right and
i spoke about specifically abortion
within the black community
sometimes black women have bought their
babies three times higher than other
communities well isn't it but the reason
behind that is because planned
parenthood
more particularly was created for
it was the eugenics movement exactly
yeah it was like that's exactly it
that's like the main issue however
that's changed
and more white women apparently are
getting abortions
okay you could say no no because i've
done the research on it anyway i'm gonna
go use the restroom okay
wait